do you work or volunteer with a really
remarkable woman someone who's truly
extraordinary in the community
and her family and friends next star our
parent company
has begun their search for remarkable
women across the united states
kirsten joyce joining us now with how
you can nominate that special woman
and a look back at the remarkable women
of 2020 in southern nevada kirsten
brian next star's kicking this off once
again wanting to highlight these
incredible women in local communities
and that woman could also be chosen as
the next star woman of the year
out of the hundreds of applicants last
time four southern nevada women were
highlighted in early 2020.
this is the story of a woman who's
dedicated her life to others the
southern nevada chapter of the american
red cross nominated diane orgill and she
was ultimately chosen as next star's
remarkable woman of the year for las
vegas
she inspired students for more than 20
years as an educator she also helped
create the very first
spay and neuter clinic in las vegas
volunteer
humanitarian teacher wife
friend diane has many roles
no one of them small diane currently
volunteers for the american red cross
available
all hours of the day and night helping
people through some of their most
vulnerable hours
you're one of a kind and you're one of
our kind and we're so proud of you
she lives a life of service betsy dunn
one of the finalists nominated for her
life of love and selflessness
changing the lives of countless children
in the valley during two decades
she and her husband fostered nearly 150
children and adopted seven
these kids come from nowhere and
they need to know that they are somebody
we see a lot of need in the community
finalist marnie domoroski works for a
local christian radio station
she reached out to a friend battling
terminal cervical cancer
moved the family right next door
prepared meals took the kids shopping
used the short time they had to preserve
precious memories for the kids
she was a fighter she loved her kids she
loved being a mother
and so she didn't want to give up she
wanted every opportunity
that she had finding herself a single
mother of three young children
and finalists lawana finch had two
decades of military service
earning her the rank of command sergeant
major and non-commissioned officer of
the year
she transitioned from military medicine
to groundbreaking work at the university
of utah artificial heart research
laboratory
nominated by her children sometimes like
everyone else thinking
i could have been better i could have
done this but i think
um because of my ethics my integrity
uh and my strictness that
that all played a big part in their
lives today
those four women inspiring examples for
what we
are looking for in the 2021 next star
woman of the year
so if you got someone in mind go to
eightnewsnow.com nominate someone
special
the nomination window closes december
20th that in march will feature the
finalist and in april
the remarkable woman from las vegas
could become the next star woman of the
year
back to you denise